SPEAKER 1: OK, thank you
everyone for joining us today.
We are super excited to have
the entire cast of SKIN,
which is the third
theatrical production put on
by Deaf Spotlight.
SKIN will be showing at
the 12th avenue theater
main stage the first
two weeks of May,
and it was written
by Crystal Roberts
and directed by
Alexandria Wailes.
It's performed in American
Sign Language, as you'll see,
with English captions.
And the story follows
four deaf, queer women
who are struggling to make
sense of violence, sex,
and love and friendship amidst a
changing landscape in Seattle's
Capitol Hill.
Deaf Spotlight is an
organization based right here
in Seattle, and they have
the mission of inspiring,
encouraging, and
showcasing creative works
of and by and for deaf people
in the Pacific Northwest.
They put on all kinds of really
cool productions and offerings.
They put on the Seattle deaf
film festival, Epic Jams,
theatrical productions,
group art exhibits,
and they also have a deaf
drama group for youth.
So now, the cast will perform
an excerpt from the play
and then afterward we'll have
and a panel session, I'll
let them take it away.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Thank you, guys.
That was awesome.
We'll go ahead and
open it for Q&A,
but first why don't each
of you introduce yourself.
Tell us your role in the play
and a little bit about how
the play was designed.
PATTY LIANG: Sure.
So hi, my name is Patty Liang.
I'm the executive director
for Deaf Spotlight.
We'll talk more
about that later.
Let's just do introductions.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Hi, my
name is Alexandris Wailes.
I'm the director
for the show, and I
want to thank Alanis
from the New York office
for getting here today.
MICHELLE MARY SCHAEFER: Hi, my
name is Michelle Mary Schaefer.
I am playing Ash.
KALEN FEENY: My
name is Kalen Feeny.
I am playing Quinn.
RHONDA COCHRAN: My
name is Rhonda Cochran,
and I am playing Rose.
AMELIA HENSLEY: And my name is
Amelia, and I am playing Sammy.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
We just finally got
the three different versions
of the script pared down
to the final version,
so we're in the process
of rehearsing at this time,
and we're opening on May 5th.
We have some minor
adjustments to make
until we get to
that point, so thank
you so much for joining us today
and being part of that process.
PATTY LIANG: And thank
you, Google and Anna,
as well for the
opportunity to come here
and showcase this production
that we're putting on.
I wish that Crystal
Roberts could be here,
unfortunately she
couldn't, she's the writer.
But the history of
Deaf Spotlight, I'll
just give a little
bit of that history.
We do cinema as well as visual
arts and performing arts,
those are our three
areas of expertise.
And we believe in
supporting artists
in each of those avenues
because there are often not
enough deaf artists in
any of these fields,
and we really want
to see that change.
We want to support artists
in each of those fields
that we are working in, and
want to give the opportunity
for deaf artists to
show their stories
and add their voice to
the stage and create
higher visibility for the deaf
community in film, theater,
and art.
So we're trying to
create opportunities
that inspire people to be
artists and start to join
the art community as well.
We're trying to give
people opportunities
to work in the field, as well as
some experience in that field.
And how Crystal fits into
that picture and this show,
we had an open call
for playwrights,
any deaf playwrights,
and we chose this script
and we are in the second
year of the production
process with that.
We got a second script
from a hearing writer
which was translated into
American Sign Language, that
was our second show.
And then we wanted
to do something
that was local, that
was really inspired
by it's environment, that's
where Crystal Roberts came in.
She is a writer and she wrote
this script two years ago,
submitted it to
us, we told her we
wanted to hear her story of
her experience of Seattle
and the Pacific Northwest
area, so she wrote us
a script in that vein.
She's a deaf woman who
has lived in the area.
She went through a long process
of developing this script,
and we did some test
reads, et cetera.
Now we're excited
to start working
with this finished
script with our cast here
and flesh out the
real concept entirely,
that's been part of the process.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Yeah, often
as I'm working with the script,
I look at some of the
language, and some of it
I have on my phone
here, get it to load.
So her words, she
says, I wrote SKIN
for personal and political
reasons, this is Crystal,
because I have not yet
seen a real representation
of deaf, lesbian women on stage.
And this is a story
about the women
that I have broken bread
with, that I cherish,
Butch, Dykes,
Queers, none of them
often represented on stage.
So, I was searching
for an outlet
that encompassed both of my
identities as queer and deaf.
Because there is a
disproportionate rate
of suicide and
mental health issues
and addiction in our
community and every day we
go through these
struggles, we have
to find meaning
in our friendships
and in the violent political
climate in which we live.
Theater seems like the
perfect outlet for this.
These characters
which I have written
are deep, personal
collage, and it
is an image of the people
whose shoulders the future will
stand on.
It is important to
me that their story
is told, that these characters
are complex without judgment
of good or bad, and show
them in this world which
is unkind to them,
the resilience
that they have with themselves
and with one another.
And it is also a farewell
letter to my beloved community
which I have seen
change significantly
in the last decade.
The process itself has
been a great journey,
from the request to
the initial script,
to finally understanding the
depth of the story until it
has reached the stage.
So those are Crystal's
comments that she sent to me.
ALL SPEAKERS: Wow.
Thank you for sharing that.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Yeah, it
was beautiful, I thought.
In addition to what Patty
said, I think for deaf women,
in work in many different
capacities in the theater,
writing, directing, et cetera,
I am really appreciative
of Patty's support.
I came here from New
York, I'm visiting,
and we all came together to
create this piece together
from all over.
And we have to always
find this inner strength
to keep going on and continuing
our work all over the country
as deaf women in this art.
PATTY LIANG: Of the four women
that we have who are cast,
three of them are
from out of state.
Michelle is from Austin, we have
Kalen from Portland, Oregon,
and then Rhonda is the
one who's from Seattle,
and Amelia is from L.A.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
Do you want to talk
a little bit about your role
in the show, each of you?
MICHELLE MARY
SCHAEFER: I've been
acting now for a long time,
but kind of professionally
for a couple of years.
I got my degree in
Deaf Education at RIT,
and then I had my
master's there,
and then I was Billy
in Tribes I was
the first deaf female
actress to take on that role
and I faced a lot of challenges.
I played Billy three
times, in 2016,
and I traveled with
that show a little bit,
and that has led me
to here, so that's
been my process of
becoming an actor.
KALEN FEENY: I'm
a script writer.
I've been living in
L.A for about 10 years
and I recently moved
back to Portland.
I've been writing
my own short films
and I'm interested in
getting into television
writing as well.
So I have sort of two
avenues that I'm pursuing
and really there is just
not enough deaf characters
in television period, so that's
one of my motivations for that.
I am trying to develop my
skills in a few different areas.
RHONDA COCHRAN: And
I'm just an actor.
I am an actor here, I've
been an actor for a bit.
I haven't done a lot, I
enjoy going to the theater.
I've worked as a deaf
interpreter as well.
So my experience in the theater
has really been social justice,
area of expertise
is social justice,
political, national
deaf advocacy work.
I was a trainer, and so
that's been my field,
my area of expertise.
But I have learned so much
by being involved with SKIN.
Being involved in
this experience
has been a wonderful experience,
wonderful process, that's
a little bit about who I am.
AMELIA HENSLEY: Hi
there, I feel like I
started acting in the womb,
probably in my mother's belly.
I'm from a deaf family,
so we were very visual,
it's been incorporated into
my life from the get go.
I went to Gallaudet university
in D.C., graduated from there
with a degree in
education, and then I
became involved with
Spring Awakening.
I had a lot of
opportunities that I
think often deaf people don't
get in the arena of acting,
I've been involved in
some shows on Broadway.
To be a deaf actor, you want to
get work, you have to travel,
you have to travel
across the country.
And that's great, you get
to go all over the country
and meet beautiful women
like these here today,
and have this kind
of experience.
It feels good to be among
deaf people, in a deaf cast,
I feel like I've come home by
being part of this experience.
PATTY LIANG: Should I say
something about myself?
OK well, I went to the
University of Washington, yay,
Anna and I were both alumni from
there, and I studied ceramics.
I grew up mainstream.
I went to public school, but I
have deaf siblings, a brother
and sister, and we all
worked with interpreters,
going to public school.
And then I went to college, and
I was seeking my own identity
as a deaf person in the deaf
community here in Seattle.
I was also picking up who I
am as an artist along the way.
So I went to college.
I went to a residency
program, met other artists,
and then as a deaf
artist, I wasn't
meeting other deaf artists.
I went to graduate school and
set up this organization, Deaf
Spotlight, and I was
thinking about the future
of deaf artists, what I had
before, where it was at,
and where I'd like it to go,
what I'd like for deaf artists
to have in the future.
So working with
this kind of group,
this kind of a cast,
this production,
I really believe that all of
us have our own community,
our own space and
we need to support
our internal space, our
creativity, what inspires us
and spread that and share
it with the community
that we live in.
Deaf, queer community, they
tend to be different groups,
different groups of people.
I don't know if you
want to add to That Want
to talk about the LGBT community
here, about how to bring people
together?
Right, out in the world, we
have this intersectionality,
what it means to
be deaf plus what
it means to be a lesbian,
what it means to be queer,
what is the a story out there.
So I'm excited to work
with this group, this cast,
to provide this opportunity
and this viewpoint
to a broader community.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
Right, we work
with the creative team
for this performance,
and it's only in ASL.
The reason we've done
that is because we really
want people to have
that experience
rather than listening to
a voiceover of the actors
in their performance.
We want people to really
get into the space,
really become part of
what we're sharing.
It's with intention
that we do this,
we've created the sign space.
I grew up as a dancer, and I
went to University of the Arts
in Pennsylvania.
And it was a broad
area of study.
I did some performance work
in that area, choreography,
directing, for the
stage, for small groups,
for web based small films,
and made that transition
back and forth.
It became an opportunity
that was there,
and I'm not one
to sit by and just
wait for things to be handed
to me and then take it on.
I wanted to make things happen.
So I found that the reality is,
there are many of us out there
but we need to find an
outlet, a way for us
to interact with
the broader world
to create this kind of a space.
And to do that we have
to meet it halfway.
So this kind of a story creates
that space, Crystal's writing,
all of us here.
It's inspiring.
It's a breath of
fresh air for people.
You know, we've been
on this journey,
so it's nice to
finally meet it here.
PATTY LIANG: Ana are
there other questions?
AUDIENCE 1: OK, so my question
is sort of a two part question.
One is about Deaf Spotlight,
and one is about SKIN
in particular, but they're
really both the same question.
And when you're doing
something that's so focused,
right, so we're talking about an
intersection of two communities
where we now have a really small
community, because obviously
your audience isn't going to be
all people of that community.
You're hoping to share
that experience with people
outside the community.
So how do you make it
accessible to those people
without diluting the experience?
How do you make
it so that people
who aren't deaf and aren't
queer and aren't any
of those things,
how do you do that
without losing what
makes that special?
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Do you
appreciate the theater?
Do you appreciate
going to the theater?
Then come, right?
It's open to everybody.
I mean, I think
that's the point.
Please do come, it's
not a closed group.
We want people to
feel like, you know,
we don't want them to
think that specific story,
specific community, specific
group of people that we're
trying to cater to, it's
really for people to come to,
theater goers.
It's a small community
with human issues,
but it's applicable to anybody,
it's applicable to any group.
We all have that
commonality, we all
have that space where
we have common ground.
And theater is
such a great venue
to explore that, it's
welcoming, it's inviting,
we want people to
come, we want people
to learn about other stories,
other groups of people.
So the theater is a
great space for that.
Please put out the
word, advertise,
we want people to come,
it's a great experience.
Amelia and I, we worked on
Spring Awakening together
on Broadway, and a lot of
people who came, they were like,
oh it's a musical with deaf
actors why should I go to that?
And then they came,
and they were like,
oh, it's not just
about deaf actors,
it's about communication,
It's about the story,
it's a human story, it's
about the connection.
It happens that
it's with teenagers
finding themselves,
coming of age,
something we all have
been through, right.
We've all been
teenagers, so that's
the bigger catch for everybody.
We can all connect
with that, it's a lens
that we're looking
through and it's powerful,
so please do come.
AUDIENCE 2: I was
wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about the challenges
and opportunities of writing
and performing and ASL.
INTERPRETER: That's a good
question, Patty's deferring.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
So talking about some
of the challenges in
a signed performance.
RHONDA COCHRAN: Sure
one thing that I've
noticed that is
particularly challenging,
the script itself was written
in English right, of course,
and then sometimes it doesn't
translate well to ASL.
It's not a direct translation,
so we're like a little stuck,
like how do we do this,
how do we sign that,
where do we go with that, how
do express that concept that
can be clearly
accessible to people
in a way that's meaningful
that we get it from the script.
It's a big challenge.
And luckily we have a lot
of support for each other,
we've had a lot of
discussions back and forth.
Crystal would show
up in the evening
than we would just hammer
her with questions.
What do you think about this?
What do you think about that?
And I feel like that process,
it's been a big challenge,
but you know, translating
from English to ASL
and how to express it and not
lose the meaning behind it.
KALEN FEENY: Another
challenge has
been with the written
script, the words,
you could hear the words,
you know oftentimes they
have a double meaning.
You have a pun, so it could
And when we sign it, ASL
has different language,
different puns, so
different from English
the grammatic structure
is very different.
So when you see that
double meaning in English,
or layers of meaning,
we're thinking
about how to come up with
something equivalent in ASL
that will be meaningful,
that will hit the mark
and honor that language that
we're seeing in written form.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
Let me just give
an example, one of the
phrases from the script
that we spent a lot
of time on discussing,
razor burn, the
concept of razor burn.
So the context is there when
you watch the play, where we're
using it on the
body, how it shows up
in ASL really is reflective of
what it means in the script.
So, is it on the face?
Is it on the arms,
or somewhere else?
So we really had to
play with that in ASL
and figure out a way
to give the information
but not give too
much because it's
a little bit of an entendre.
Razor burn, you know, if I
just said that doesn't really
have the meaning.
However, if we
identify where, wow, it
does have a lot of meaning.
So those kinds of things
would come up in the script,
and how to make that maintained
and meaningful in ASL
with four deaf women who come
from various backgrounds,
from different educational
backgrounds, how they express
themselves, it varies.
They didn't go to
the same school.
They didn't grow up in
the same communities.
Their ASL may be
different depending
on where they grew up.
So being respectful
of that, and seeing
that in the development of
this script, and honoring it.
Deaf bodies, deaf women,
it's been very interesting.
This journey has
been interesting.
RHONDA COCHRAN: Do you mind
if I add something too?
I noticed as well, with the
character development of Rose,
and thinking about
myself, my background, who
I am, as a lesbian, yes,
I'm a black woman as well,
what does that mean?
You know, did I grow up oral?
Did I grow up learning sign?
The deaf community, it can vary.
You know, if you
go to a mainstream
school, public school,
residential school
for the deaf, those all have
huge impacts on language
development and how we
communicate with the world.
Maybe I learned pigeon
sign language or ASL
or English order sign language.
It all varies and that
all affects our thinking
and how we approach this script.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Are
there other questions?
PATTY LIANG: I'd
like to add as well,
so the writer,
Crystal Roberts, she
has a specific vision
of the four characters.
And she gave us some
hints, some stories,
background of these women, but
it was their responsibility
to really flesh
out the characters,
to go on the journey to
experience it to internalize
some behaviors that they think
that their character would
exemplify.
Crystal didn't give
that information.
She was very inspired by
what she saw in the community
here in Seattle and
as we move forward,
it really created a mosaic.
A mosaic has been created by
these four actors, these four
women.
One other thing I'd like
to add, Crystal, she really
wanted to work with a women
only team, women only director,
women actors, all the
volunteers, everybody
on the set, everybody
involved with the production
would be women to make it a
very safe space for everybody.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
Right, this has
been a truly unique experience
because of that energy.
It's very different.
We're used to
something different,
so it's very different really.
PATTY LIANG: Deaf
Spotlight, this
is the first time we've
done a women only team,
a women only production,
first time in three years.
It's exciting, and I think
that there will be more
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: And yes,
so however you identify, come!
It's not only for women,
that's not the point,
I don't think that's the
point Patty is making.
PATTY LIANG: Right, if you
go to the film or theater,
you go to a film festival,
they have different groups that
have different film
festivals, but you're
interested in learning
more about that group
so you might go in for a couple
of hours and kind of delve
into their life by
viewing this film
and feel what they are feeling.
Really, any expression
through the arts
is valid and
valuable and creating
a safe space for
discussion and that process
in a healthy positive way.
And someone asks
about the challenges
of producing this
piece, I think it always
depends on the script itself.
How many characters do you need?
What kind of director
are you looking for?
What's the energy of the piece?
What kind of actors
are you trying to cast?
Who will express these
characters that best on stage?
And getting the people,
the right people
to be involved with
the production, that's
always a challenge.
It's a team effort.
It's a huge
collaboration, so getting
everyone's different
perspectives
and bringing that
all together is--
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
As a director,
I do believe that the
collaborative process,
and having that collaborative
space when we are creating
each character,
is really inspired
by the collection
of individuals.
It's never just one person.
I know I go through
each of these characters
four times, right,
with each character.
And then all of
those experiences,
that's the challenge of getting
the language of the play,
or the language of theater.
Often it's a process
and we're often
working with both deaf
and hearing people
and sign language is not
always natural in those mixed
environments.
You have to bring
interpreters in, there
is a little bit of a language
delay, just enough for it
to be noticeable.
I know that I signed
quickly, right,
so I'm working with
interpreters and sometimes I
have to make
adjustments for them
and the interpreter's
catching up
to me, and that sort of thing.
You have to have time
to listen and respond
and that adds time
to the process.
I sometimes have to keep
in mind and open myself
up to being flexible
with that accommodation
because we're working
with these two languages
and you're also working
with one and other,
and each of those
people in that process
needs to be honored as well.
And as a deaf actor in a
production with a script that's
already been produced
in English and you're
working on translating
that process,
you want to honor the meaning
and the intent of that piece,
and that takes a lot of time.
There's a lot of
discussion around that.
I want to give the
cast about a week
beforehand, before
we start actually
rehearsing to just get
into the script, start
understanding what it
means in American Sign
Language for them.
We sat down and had a
discussion about how
we would sign some
of these concepts
with each of the actors,
what each line meant.
Those puns, like Kalen
mentioned, translating
a lot of the work really.
And then when we
started rehearsals
we already had a good sense
in our bodies of the direction
that we were going
with the piece,
so it's different from
a hearing actor who
might just read from a script.
They might go through a table
read just reading the lines,
but we are reading
these lines, we
need to understand the
intent of the piece,
and then translate
from the English
into a meaningful expression of
that work in our own language.
So that takes a lot
of time and energy
and we really try to
honor that entire process.
PATTY LIANG: And if you happen
to know any other scripts out
there, especially if they're
deaf authors, let me know.
Any other questions?
This is your opportunity, so.
AUDIENCE 3: You just mentioned
other scripts, what kind
of other projects do you
have coming up, if anything?
PATTY LIANG: Well, Deaf
Spotlight, after SKIN closes,
will be shifting our
focus to our drama camp.
We have a youth drama
camp in the summers that's
a two week, free day camp
for deaf and hard of hearing
and children of deaf
adults ages 8 to 13.
So we're hiring deaf artists,
professionals to come and work
with those youth teaching them
drama and other forms of art.
And then we also have a
film festival coming up
in the spring, so if you're
interested in other events that
are public, that
one's coming up.
It's going to be an
international film festival
that's hosted here in Seattle.
We have films from Japan,
Australia, New Zealand,
all over.
All of them in different
signed languages, each country
has their own, and
they are all subtitled.
So it's just like
watching a foreign film,
and in fact, they
are foreign films.
So that's exciting as
well and that's coming up.
Did you have any other projects
that you're working on?
Anyone else in the cast or crew.
AMELIA HENSLEY: Yeah, I have
a project that's coming up.
I will have a film
in the festival.
ALL SPEAKERS: Yeah,
that's so exciting.
MICHELLE MARY SCHAEFER:
My next project
is looking for another
acting opportunity.
I'm trying to focus
on my web series,
I've found some work
there so, I'm working
on one that's being developed.
And then I'm setting up a
deaf theater in Austin, DAT,
and that's with Russell Harvard
and [? Bellamy, ?] I think
I'm spelling his
last name right,
Bellamy [? Aquillie, ?] I'm not
sure if I spelled that right,
but the three of us are
establishing a theater
in Austin called the Deaf
Austin Theater and we're just
in the beginning stages of that.
Hopefully we'll be doing
more shows there in Austin.
So I'm looking forward
to that, and maybe I
can bring some of
these folks over there.
Maybe Deaf Spotlight's
interested in getting involved.
We'll talk to Crystal
as well, but I
would like to see SKIN
produced there potentially.
KALEN FEENY: I have a
few projects coming up.
I just did a TV Pilot and also
a feature film that I'm writing.
There's a few women
involved in that
and there's a new play that's
being written that I'm working
on with some other people.
And then Patty mentioned before
about providing opportunities
for deaf artists in the
future, and personally,
I would like to start developing
workshops to teach storytelling
and writing for deaf
artists and signing people
because going through the
process of becoming a writer,
and looking for opportunities
as a deaf writer,
there's really very few.
I think I was very fortunate.
And I want to
bring my experience
to a larger group
of deaf artists
as well, so I'd like to
start working on the project.
RHONDA COCHRAN: My
next step is, I'm
a deaf interpreter for Dream
Girls, for the village theater,
so that's my next project.
Once I'm done here, I'll be
studying for that project,
so that's what's next for me.
AMELIA HENSLEY: I just did, I
think I just talked about mine.
Just the film that's coming and
that's all, and sleep and food.
RHONDA COCHRAN: Yes, that too.
PATTY LIANG: Do you have
anything else you want to add?
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Well,
I will land in New York
and hit the ground running when
I'm done with this project.
So I have a few ASL
consulting jobs for a stage,
and one web series
that's coming up.
And then I have another project
in the works, which I'm not
allowed to fully
disclose at the moment
until I have that
contract signed.
PATTY LIANG: Alexandria and I
will be working again together
during the camp this summer,
so I'm looking forward to that.
And if you're wondering how you
can support the deaf community
in the future and
Deaf Spotlight,
you can come to
our events, you can
donate to projects, and share
information with your friends.
If they don't know anything
about the deaf community,
this is a great
opportunity to get a taste.
And we want to be connecting
with other communities as well,
and if you have
people who are wanting
to do that, refer
them to us, they
get to see a new perspective.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES: Yeah,
and I think for outsiders,
a lot of people don't understand
what the deaf community offers.
We have this concept
of deaf gain,
and we know that the
deaf community has a lot
to offer the world.
These successes are a
result of our experiences
and our own lens and
experience the world,
and we want to share that.
So it can expand your own way
of thinking about the world
by coming to experience what it
means to live in a visual world
because we're visual beings and
people often maybe rely on what
they hear, but we have a
different way of picking up
on what's going on around
us and seeing the world.
So that's one way that you can--
RHONDA COCHRAN:
Yeah, I just wanted
to add to that like
you were saying before.
You know, the death experience
is a human experience.
We all go through the
same things in our lives,
we experience
heartbreak, we experience
many different challenges
in our lives, [INAUDIBLE]
violence, maybe sexual
violence, we have
so many diverse experiences.
And experiencing this piece, or
other pieces by deaf artists,
gives us an opportunity
to relate to one another
on that human level.
ALEXANDRIA WAILES:
Yeah, and you'll
see these four amazing actors
in their prime as well.
PATTY LIANG: And if you're
following us on social media,
we have hashtag, deaf talent,
deaf talent is the hashtag.
If you follow us
there, you can keep
track of what's going on with
Deaf Spotlight and deaf talent
and see what's
coming up or support
any of the projects
that are going on.
Yeah, we have some
posters here if you
want to take some with you.
Yeah, any other questions?
SPEAKER 1: No, I think we
should just thank our speakers
and thank you guys for
coming and for giving us
such a wonderful performance.
This was really great.
ALL SPEAKERS: Yeah, thank
you so much as well.
Thank you for the opportunity.